right now i feel like i'm in uh my
childhood you know
back in the womb hot in there
[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
week feast i'm shawn evans and you're
watching hot ones
it's the show with hot questions and
even hotter wings and today we're joined
by michael che
he's a stand-up comedian and actor who's
received five emmy nominations for his
work as head writer and cast member on
saturday night live
also be sure to check out his new sketch
comedy show that damn michael che which
is currently streaming on hbo max
michael che welcome to the show thank
you it's so weird to hear people say
that out loud you know
i can't believe i'm here how are you
around spicy food
i don't i've never seen any of these at
my local bodega but
um i like spicy food i think i like
spicy food that might all change tonight
[Music]
i'm like nervous but i'm eating uh fish
sticks by the way
first first uh fish stick guys yeah i
just didn't want to eat chicken on
camera
that's not [ __ ]
[Music]
can i say whatever i want yes let it fly
i killed the man in 1972. wait not that
one not that one
so for what it's worth i watched that
damn michael che in one sitting it
really is like the perfect
canvas for you to explore concepts that
are maybe
darker than the things you can talk
about on network television
you liked it you watched the whole thing
i did i did
blows my mind you want to know my
favorite sketch yeah what
i like the uh billy porter superhero one
yeah that i just thought it'd be fun you
know what i i got that actually from
a very unhelpful tsa agent but now yeah
that was a fun one too billy porter is
amazing isn't he
it made me wonder like does the idea of
that come first or does billy porter
come first and then you write for billy
porter because
it did have like a really nice
connection it was the idea
and then we were like oh man billy
porter you know billy porter is so
good that he's like if you're not if
you're not using him you're using a
billy porter type
you know like oh billy porter would kill
this and he actually said yes a lot of
the
casting on it was uh first choices so i
was
really lucky that they said yes and
that's just like a funny concept the
idea of like a superhero that never
really gets around to saving the day
because they're just serving out that
attitude
it was great he made his own costume he
cares more about the costume and his
entrance
[Laughter]
i've had hot ice cream i'm gonna kill
this [ __ ]
so naturally i have to ask you about the
hot ones saturday night live sketch
with a sweat soaked my rudolph playing
the role of beyonce and then mikey day
playing the role of this show's
incessant bald host he nailed you
mikey's such a good
like i used to write with him sometimes
you know on sketches
and you'd be in a room and he's always
in his head and trying to get everything
perfect i don't think anybody
approaches it as thoroughly as mike is
he's so good so like he probably watched
hours of footage to make sure he got
that right but yeah he's he's amazing
i could tell uh what can you tell us bts
on how that sketch came to be and do you
remember how it played at the table read
it was it to me it was the funniest
sketch of the episode
it was we knew it was going to be funny
because first of all it's maya
and she nails beyonce all the time and
until it was just like a fun i got
have you asked beyonce to do this no but
i do imagine that
were it to go down like that it would it
would be similar to the sketch
my favorite part is when she had to get
the wig off to
the ice cubes but ice cubes in the wig i
was so funny she probably hated it
[Music]
yeah i'm gonna taste the thing
okay this one's got like um
a little bit yeah it keeps going yes
it's uh very peppery this one mm-hmm
but it's still nothing there we go it's
still nothing
so i'm very interested in the chapter of
your life before
comedy when you were training to be a
painter and then selling t-shirts with
the acrylic still going
a little bit it just yeah it keeps
rolling it rallies through that's just a
train it's a spice train that's going to
keep rolling hey [ __ ] though
and you were selling t-shirts with your
acrylic portraits printed on them from a
folding table on the corner of prince
street and wooster
yeah what's the most memorable
transaction that you ever made on the
sidewalk there oh man i met
so many people i met um conan o'brien
billy crystal i met um tommy hilfiger
i met andre 3000 andre how did you know
that
yeah i met 100 3 000. he bought he
bought a little like jimi hendrix shirt
from me i painted a jimmy hendrix shirt
oh man yeah that's great i wasn't that
good to be honest with you
i think it was just more people wanting
to be supportive
i'm just saying man um i'm unimpressed
[Laughter]
i think this i think i'm going to get
through all of this i might just go back
for seconds
hell yeah be our guest we're just here
to feed you michael
it tastes like uh like pineapple like as
sweet as a pineapple
oh this is gonna suck man i already know
it because like that
i just realized we got like six more
that's right that's right
and they get hotter it's a marathon yeah
what's the difference between bombing on
stage as a stand-up and then having a
sketch bomb on live tv like is one more
gut wrenching than the other
yes there's nothing worse than bombing
on live tv
because um there's no exit strategy
see if i'm bombing on stage doing
stand-up i could change the subject
i can make fun of me bombing there's
always a way to relate to the people
like stand up the number one rule is uh
just be present if people see that
something awkward has happened
call it out and then people will be like
yeah that is what's happening just
the truth always kind of gets you back
on track in a sketch
sometimes if it starts bombing in the
first 30 40 seconds and we know what's
coming next there's no
typo you got to actually do the words
the audience is checked out
the only thing that is better about
bombing in the sketch though
is that everyone knows it's bombing so
it's a little bit of
camaraderie on set right you know like
if it's bombing and sometimes you just
take a look at keenan's face
and then it makes you laugh and then
everyone realizes they're seeing
something bad so a lot of sketches
you'll see
when they do make fun of us for breaking
or whatever a lot of times
breaking is just because we know what's
coming next and how bad it's going and
then it becomes
fun so sometimes i could save the sketch
so but i would definitely take bombing
in the sketch uh overbombing on stage
oh ginger i love ginger i love goat too
this is easy wow you have medics right
yeah actually we do
it's kind of a new here you development
just yeah that
makes sense but also i won't need them
crushing it crushing it i don't know
all right michael we have a recurring
segment on our show called explain that
graham we're doing deep dive on our
guest instagram pull interesting
pictures that need more context so we'll
put the picture up on the monitor you
just tell
us the bigger story that's me
at wrestlemania 35 you can't tell by the
shirt but yeah that's where i was
wrestlemania 35 in the andre the giant
battle royal
looking down the at braun strowman that
was the most fun i've ever had it was
metlife stadium 80 000 people all
booing me and colin it was awesome all
i've ever wanted was to be a bad guy
wrestler
and these people genuinely hated me it
was fantastic yeah you used to watch
wrestling with your grandfather right
what the [ __ ] did you know that yes yeah
he couldn't have told you he's been dead
for 10 years but no yeah i used to watch
it
i think like it's how i learned how to
talk honestly
you know what one thing that i notice
those ropes are not
rope it's like bridge cables you see the
guys they're so good at it that it looks
easy and simple but like the mat is a
wood plank
and the ropes are hurt when you run
against the ropes they got welts on
their back
from just doing the easiest simple
things and the ring is
loud and the crowd is deafening it was
so exciting to
to do it look my face it didn't scare
him one bit believe it or not
but he was such a nice guy and and uh he
punched me
and i dropped and i was so scared cause
you know i'm an older guy
and delicate i didn't think i was gonna
be able to take it but i did
you did and then he told me i didn't
really punch you but
whatever no no it was uh it was great it
was a lot of fun all right
up next i'm always curious about the
comedian's perspective when it comes to
hosting award shows like how would you
distill the experience of playing
ringmaster at the emmys
bad i can't i don't know if i could say
that is that okay to say that i didn't
want to host the enemies and i did
we're cool with it no i
i i was like i didn't want to do it i
always feel like yeah i just like doing
comedy in a tuxedo just feels
i look like i'm giving dinner specials i
think it was ellen
gave me the best advice she was like get
all the comedy done in the beginning
because the longer the show goes
uh the more losers are in the audience
like literally people have lost in their
nothing's funny to them anymore
so you kind of have to do all the comedy
up front and then the rest of it is
keeping the show moving
i don't know i think that's that
self-deprecating comedian inside of me
that's like i shouldn't be hosting i
should be in the back making fun of the
host
a lot of people take this very serious
so i was just like i don't want to mess
up your party you know it's like giving
a toast
at a wedding and you don't know the
couple right it just feels
out of place a little bit but hindsight
it was fun
[Music]
a little bit
oh that was good
i was good you know i like about that
one that one's not hot
is this where people start to fall apart
i'm witnessing grace
witnessing greatness no this is easy
all right that one is the hottest one
that's that's how it'll go going forward
here
but it's no problem i can see it it's no
problem
no there's no problem it's not a it's
not a problem
so a few months back you put together a
slideshow talking about how you don't
want to do
any more interviews with a few
exceptions and lucky for us one of those
exceptions was hot ones
is your disdain and doing press is that
something that you've had since day one
of your career or is it kind of
developed over time
uh no i i love press again like i said
you do this this is true
no it's you know why you know what
here's my here's why i don't like yeah
it's because i never feel like they're
on the side of
the artist they're always seemed to be
on the side
of what's the headline
you know so why would i like it if i was
a headline maybe i'd like it more but
they always kind of
want the the juicy juicy thing and also
i don't like talking about myself i
always feel weird and
arrogant talking about myself constantly
this actually that was hot like but then
it goes away
just in time for the next wing
are you ready to dive in let's do it
let's go to the [ __ ] loony bin let's
do it
i see now i get it now i get the point
of this game
hmm this one's more sweet than hot
i think it's when right when you start
talking you know
just like the last one it'll build a
little bit
i get emotional sometimes
so you're a native new yorker which is
different from a lot of comedians who
come to this city because they want to
pursue a career in acting they move here
rather than you
who grew up and was born in the lower
east side yeah
is there any special reason that you
chose naz's new york state of mind to be
your walkout song when you performed at
letterman for the first time there's no
more beautiful song than being a project
kid
um listen to new york state of mind back
in 1994
uh as soon as you turn on omatic
and that you know after the genesis and
the new york state of mind that beat
it's primo it's nas it it felt like he
was talking directly to us like he made
an album
directly for us and new york state of
mind is it brings me back to that moment
of being a kid you're just ready to take
charge it was like his moment i feel
so when i'm once when i'm coming on
stage i like to feel that i still play
it
everywhere i play it when i'm doing
warm-up fast you know
played it for letterman i play when i'm
on tour
it just feels right
dude i don't know if you notice but i am
unaffected
this is like when are we gonna do the
the hot ones
funny you mentioned that is this hot
that was good glad i i like that one
where can i get these can i go can i
these you can take home with you we'll
pack them up for you
these honestly this that one that you
just said with the hottest one is
honestly
not that hard so we sent a lot of hot
sauce like i just mentioned
to 30 rock after the beyonce hot one
sketch and then we got a quick request
to re-up on it his hot sauce helped the
creative process at all or is it just
writers kind of keeled over after eating
the bomb like we just did
i'm sorry i um i'm trying to remember
something
that's not sure how about how to ice
cream
that's good that is a good sauce no um i
i think
i think there was a few cast members and
writers
uh i'm sorry i'm just i
i think i um when are we gonna do the
hot ones
that's an interesting question i'm just
trying to give you the right answer yeah
yeah i remember
a lot of uh is this where people start
to fall apart
i don't i don't remember i don't
remember
i don't remember do you have a favorite
reaction from a
host to a sketch that you've pitched
well
sometimes people who come in with an
idea of the show
and what they want to do on the show uh
they might they might not really know
what they're talking about
or if that you know it might not even be
possible
because they don't do this show you know
so
i will pitch something they were like
well that guy's crazy
then i could write whatever i want by
myself not on the hook
you don't want them to be like oh he's
[ __ ] hilarious hey can you write my
unicycle idea no no but
so you know i try to like pretend to be
bad at my job
so that i could be good at my job does
that make sense
thinking it's reverse psychology but
then backwards
all right michael jay
how are we doing sniffing is not good
but um other than that i'm good i'm fine
this next one is the scorpion disco why
they call it that
all right
it's more salty yeah and maybe a kind of
uh
kind of a reprieve after the last one
so before making it in comedy what was
the most common buyer complaint that you
ever got working as a customer service
representative at toyota
what the [ __ ] do you know that
a lot of people will write me checks for
a car
knowing they don't got the money uh for
that car in their account and then make
it seem like i took the money somehow
and i remember that was always like the
funniest complaint is as you're
as you're making a transaction you're
like well but the check should clear
i'm like well it's not the bank doesn't
know you and uh
that was always the worst because the
salesman is always on the side of the
customer
so they make it seem like you know
you're messing it up but usually it was
just because they couldn't yell
and they just find the person to yell at
you're the first line of complaints
that's the worst part of it
you know what i mean do you have any uh
insider trade secrets when it comes to
not getting
ripped off at the dealership no they're
gonna rip you off
they're gonna rip you off because cars
are not that valuable
so anything you're paying it ain't worth
it
all right michael che
man this was so much fun i want to thank
you
i tell you what shawn i tell you what i
raise you
uh oh
i raise you okay i don't know if
anyone's done this before but i say
we put a dab of all of them on one wing
has anyone done that before paul rudd
and now uh and now you michael j
that's what they call me the black pole
red
oh it's like paste god damn oh there you
go there you go
is that it that's that's good
yeah man you didn't think he was [ __ ]
with a gangster did you i knew i was
[ __ ] with a gangster yeah well you
are [ __ ] a gangster
oh [ __ ] well that might be a lot but
don't worry about it
that's what that's what i want the
context people to know
is when i'm you see me sweating it looks
like i'm maybe even crying
it's because i had a rough week yeah
you know what i'm saying can you can you
play some good montage music
to this oh don't yeah don't worry you
know what i'm saying in the production
truck
we will wait till you see how this thing
comes together
i got dinner reservations too you do
where you going tonight
oh i don't know um baskin robbins
i might be right behind you online
basketball paul ryan is the nicest guy
he is the nicest guy hey you know who
else is super nice
who john hamm yeah yeah yeah we gotta
get john ham on the show
yeah all right michael
get that sauce
[Music]
you know what i'm saying cheers cheers
it's like they cancel each other out
i think at first it does because we
worked in reverse order but
when you work your way through that
you've got some
different notes
[Music]
michael che hot sauce g
i'm going to am i on the short list of
g's
top of the list top of the list michael
and you know
thankfully though we've reached and i
didn't touch the milk i noticed that no
water no milk
g not michael j know what i'm saying
we've talked about a lot about your life
a lot about your career but one blind
you don't don't oh don't lick your lips
yeah that's good advice that's good
advice if you're on this show
don't lick your lips smart man michael
smart man
what did you mean by this quote humor
and food are two things rich in a poor
community
see when you grow up very poor
you don't have you can't just go to the
toy store get whatever you want you
can't just go shopping whenever you want
the way we show affection is to cook
and to make you laugh and that [ __ ] gets
you through
oh man i get emotional talk on my past
i'm sorry
um is that that's a
that's supposed to help right yeah yeah
but we don't need it we don't need it
[Music]
it's uh
oh man uh looks so good uh
it's uh two things of showing love you
know
[Music]
it brings you back to your childhood
right now i feel like i'm in my
childhood you know
back in the womb hot in there
this is not how you show love no this
wouldn't be the food i would show
give to someone that i loved but you
know what
it's a meal there were laughs i feel the
love in the studio and look at you
michael che taking on the wings of death
even attack last dab and now
totally unaffected joe's fake there's
nothing left to do but roll out the red
carpet for you michael che
this camera this camera this camera let
the people know what you have going on
in your life
the show's fake it's a sham all this is
this is sweet sauce
i got a lot going on guys tomorrow i'm
making a visit to my cardiologist
we're gonna talk about uh ways to
improve upon my lifestyle
oh man and don't burp don't burp
it's just like uh comes back
burps what time is it
we did it man we did it
i love you guys i couldn't have done
this without you and i wouldn't have
oh man that's good
that was good that was easy
did it hurt of course it hurt his hand
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you dude oh
my god how do you do that
well you know most people don't want to
pour the last 10 sauces on the last one
i thought you challenged me
[Laughter]
this is actually fun this is so much fun
i don't know what i'm talking about
anymore
quickly we're going to get our intro so
it's just you guys sure okay
hey what's going on hot ones fans this
is shawn evans checking in with a very
exciting hot sauce update
los calientes barbacoa it's finally here
baby this sauce right here
evokes all the flavors of barbecue but
then with a smoky mix
of serrano and habanero chilies perfect
for slow roasting meats
perfect for slathering on burritos
grilling vegetables
get your hands on los calientes barbacoa
heatness.com
heatness.com heatness.com to order
all summer long we're having the remix
of the remix
hot ones barbacoa unofficial official
sauce of grilling and chilling